so when you have a look at this guy down
here right which one's f of X think
again look again it's an x squared plus
X right so that's this guy that's f of X
now what I'm asking us to do for this is
graph again the subtraction so I haven't
given you X plus 4 have I the other line
what is it
have a look at the graph can you tell me
from the graph what's the equation this
is y equals the opposite the negative of
G of X which in this case is minus X
minus 4 the minus X gives us this
downward gradient right and the minus 4
tells us what the y-intercept is right
there okay so you with me
so I've turned this subtraction problem
into an addition problem now let's just
add these two okay where would you like
me to go like that right so what I'm
doing is I'm thinking about x squared
plus X take away X plus 4 I'm saying
that's the same as x squared plus X plus
minus X minus 4 and that's the problem
I'm now doing visually okay you're
following yep yep so I've got this minus
4 right you might notice it like what's
the point that corresponds to that it's
like way above it's like oh it's so far
up there okay so when I draw my red
graph my real graph it's gonna have to
be quite high up here
okay so I'll get to that in a minute
I've got other x-intercepts third don't
know got next intercept there yep you
can draw it wherever you like really
just go for it right so I'm gonna go
down to there what does that look like
to you what Y values that look like to
you that looks like negative three to me
yep and just like before zero plus
negative three is negative three so
that's where my X goes I've got another
one here I'm gonna go down to negative
four thank you very much right there
zero plus negative four hopefully you're
getting sick of me saying this right
zero
plus something is just whatever that
something is okay like that okay now
that's only two points really I feel
like I need more information can you
look on the graph and tell me I've gone
through my x-intercepts where might be
another useful place I could look okay
yep so I can see you're talking about
the Y value yeah right so that value
there is two so what's the other Y value
all the way down here what's that look
like negative five what's two plus
negative five negative three so in fact
I'm just gonna call this a little bit
different right so I'm just gonna make
this green so negative three is in the
middle here right down that way okay
yeah you're getting you see like oh it's
turning around its turn right is there
another point you can tell me that might
be useful maybe maybe I look around here
is there any like nice whole numbers you
can see yeah I've got again 2 and minus
2 what happens when you have 2 and minus
2 they collapse together and they give
you zero like that so I'm gonna have it
probably going through here okay so I'm
gonna get this parabola right all right
so I really do love my fella so I'm
gonna do my very best now and I'm going
to try and connect the dots okay so I
think I'm gonna get something like whoo
all right wish me luck I'm gonna start
from I'm actually gonna cheat a little
bit sorry I'm joining this upside down
cuz you can turn your page around but I
anyway so now I'm gonna go
like that and then on this side what
have I got here let me see here I'm just
looking I'm just making sure I do this
like reasonably accurately for you guys
how does that look to you guys you're
happy with that okay and you might
notice I had to do like a couple a few
lines to make sure it was accurate but
you're asking your question so here's my
suggestion to you and this is just a
practical thing right I've got colors
that's fancy right but when I'm doing
this in the exam what I do is I do all
my working in pencil and I try and do it
quite lightly right and then when I'm
like I'm ready I've drawn my graph
through this is what I want to be v8r
then I go over that in pen and it's like
that's the only thing in pen here and I
know I'm gonna get it right because I
already like you know did it wrong a
couple of times I fixed it up and then I
just go over that thing in pen okay now
I'm gonna do one last check right let's
do this algebraically and see what
happens how many x-squared toes will I
end up with I'll just get the single x
squared what about the X terms they they
cancel down a plus X minus X so no X's
what about the constant term it's just
minus 4 this is difference of two
squares what's the factorization X minus
2 X plus 2 and so you can see the two
roots you should get from that do they
match with what our red graph tells us
minus 2 plus 2 BAM I'm done okay that
makes sense